Okay, so hey!
Oh, Snuffy's here!
Hey!
Hey, Snuffy.
You're in trouble.
What?
Oh, what?
What did I do?
I don't know.
Don't, don't, don't.
It tells me that instead of hanging out with me in real life, you were hanging out with an A.I.
version of me.
Limu, Limu, Limu.
No, nobody could ever replace you.
Oh, yeah, you were asking her if she plays League.
I saw her.
Limu, I'll have you know that somebody, somebody is defaming your name.
They are, they are.
Somebody, I don't, your most popular, like, A.I.
personality is literally just wrote to be, like, admitting how bad you are at video games.
Like, everything you say is just like, I need to be carried.
I am so bad.
I don't even know how to use a controller.
I'm, I'm malicious.
So, yeah, but why are you, why are you hanging out with A.I.
version of her instead of the actual version of her, huh?
It was practice.
I get social anxiety.
If you need me to talk mean about myself to you, Snuffy, I will do, I guess.
Oh, no!
Oh, so LabCons gives you social anxiety so you have to talk to a computer version of her?
It's like trying to make a doctor's appointment.
A.I.
friendships.
What if you, what if you, do you like A.I.
Laimu?
What if you like her more than real Laimu?
Yeah, yeah, what do you do?
I don't, I don't.
She's a mockery.
I was fighting for my queen's behalf.
Then why didn't you tell her?
Why did you, why did you have to get snitched out?
No, I'm here now.
I'm here to relate to you.
Yeah, but you were late talking to A.I.
Laimu.
I went to pee.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I thought the collab started at...
Yeah?
Hold on a fucking second.
Are we doing a collab at 11 p.m.
my time on a Tuesday, which is exactly when the Steam servers die?
Wait, no, don't say that.
No way.
We can play Dress To Impress.
I just disconnected from Steam, so yes, yes, we are.
Wait, wait, how long?
Oh my God, there's nobody online.
I'm disconnecting from Steam.
I'm stronger.
You guys.
Wait, how long?
How long does it take?
Is it like an hour ahead?
No, it can be, it can be like a little bit.
And sometimes it takes a while for everyone to like stagger back on, so it could be a little while.
No, don't say that.
I just, I just want to absolve myself.
I didn't pick the time.
I didn't choose the time.
I tried.
Wait, I was trying to be accommodating to the only EU person here.
I was just trying to be accommodating.
Oh yeah, fuck me for trying to be accommodating to the one person that's across the world.
Like fuck it, I'll never do that again.
I'll make sure to do it in my time.
It starts only, motherfucker.
How was I supposed to know?
I even dressed up and everything.
I took off my skin suit.
Wait, turn, look what I look like.
I even dressed up.
Is he okay?
Are you wearing your uniform?
I have a uniform on.
I even got my little booster box so I can stand up and fit.
How did you work out of doors locked?
Oh no, look at that.
I even got my box.
I even got a...
I can't believe it.
I put a uniform...
I put a uniform on and everything.
And Steam servers are down?
What do you mean?
It's been like 10 minutes or so.
Wait, I think it's back.
It's back, it's back.
It's coming back.
Yes, yes.
How did you guys know?
I have yet to return.
I'm still barred from the horizon.
I got it, I'm stronger.
Wait, are you guys in the multiplayer?
How do you know it's back?
Because my Steam thing says it came back online.
See, Snuffy, this is what you get for talking with AI, Snuffy.
This is punishment for...
Well, no, maybe Snuffy actually saved us because otherwise we would have been in the middle of something with the servers down.
That's true, we had to wait for her.
Everyone on my Steam list has been online, like last online 31 days ago.
Maybe...
Yeah, it'll do that.
Maybe they were like...
I was unable to sync your fast food simulator prologue save.
Okay, so who's making the lobby?
I don't have any saves, I've never booted it before.
I've never had a save too, so I think you just click on empty, right?
I'm just gonna say fuck you, don't care.
Okay, are we using Lamu's server as well?
The one that's across the ocean?
I'm the only one in Europe, so if you all want terrible ping, go for it.
I'm still imprisoned in the forbidden zone, I'm not connected yet.
It sometimes takes a minute.
Yeah, maybe you log out of Steam and log back in.
The other day I was playing Deadlock and it took me like 25 minutes to get back online, and everyone was just sitting there like, we've been online for ages.
I thought nobody played this game.
Oh my god, I closed Steam and I forgot that that's...
Can you up yourself a little bit more?
Oh, you killed all your VTubing stuff?
Yeah, that happens.
I VTubed that way, I did that.
Yeah, I can try.
That's why people are like...
Yeah, I have you at 200%, but you're really quiet on my end.
I don't know why, because I'm in the red on my own screen.
That's weird.
Did you look at your Discord input?
Yeah, everything's maxed.
What the fuck?
That's so weird.
And it's been like with other people's streams too, so I don't know why.
Your Discord's shy.
He's a shy little guy.
I turned myself up a little bit.
The problem is, I think it's something with Discord or a compression thing on Discord maybe, because like when you say I've turned myself up, it's literally no difference.
Yeah, me too.
It's no difference, but I wanted to wait for someone else to say it.
Could you like maybe screenshot all of your audio settings?
Yeah, I mean, don't dox yourself.
Don't dox your Discord audio.
Just for laughs.
I'm not sure I could hack you via your Discord settings, but I'm happy to give it a try.
I don't know.
She's been around for a long time on the internet.
Don't trust her.
She knows.
I'm gonna hack you so hard that we'll have to use Ventrilo.
It'll be great.
What the fuck is Ventrilo?
Oh, don't start.
Is that an old internet thing?
Yes.
Oh my god, wait, how?
I'm sorry.
It's like an old voice program that people used to use for things like multiplayer games.
Wait, it's older than TeamSpeak?
Oh, I remember that, yeah.
It was like around the same time as TeamSpeak, I think.
Maybe a little bit older?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Snuffy should know what it is, because I explained it to her once.
Oh, I thought I was like a Snuffy.
We were integrating it to Dust at the same fucking time.
Yeah, I was gonna say, how does Snuffy know about it too?
Because I mentioned it.
It's 2002, I believe.
2002?!
I didn't start using it in 2002!
I was playing backyard baseball at that time.
What was I doing in 2002?
I was getting hacked in Neopets.
Oh yeah, and getting hacked in Neopets too.
I would have been playing fucking Neopets.
I remember when I played Neopets, I didn't have the parental form to access the forums, so I had to ask my parents to give me permission.
Yeah, I did too!
They faxed the permission sheet over!
Yeah, you used to have to get permission if you were under a certain age.
And then, when I was on the forums, I heard about a website called Gaia, and they were like, Gaia's PG-13.
And I was like, I never went on Gaia, because that's where the old people are.
Yeah, for the first year that I was using Gaia, I would clear my browsing history afterwards, because it was PG-13 and I thought I'd get in trouble.
So I would clear everything afterwards so my parents couldn't see!
My mom made me add her as a friend, and she would check my profile every day.
And before she'd tuck me into bed, she'd be like, why were you posting this, huh?
What was this about?
Check my history!
My mom was like a bloodhound.
Do you know what my mother used to do?
When I used to take a day off of school because I would tell her I felt sick, I would wait for her to leave, and then I would go use the internet, right?
But, we had dial-up, so what she would do is she would wait, and then she would call the house, and if she couldn't get through, she would send me an email being like, what?
She would send you an email!
That's hardcore, that she would send you a fucking email.
And she'd be like, what are you doing on the PC right now?
My parents didn't care.
I think I lied about my age for Neopets.
I'm pretty sure I did on my second account.
I absolutely did because I didn't want to have to do it again, so I lied.
People lying on the internet, that's crazy.
My parents made my Neopets account.
I literally, that was like the one thing that was like, with your parents' permission.
I remember sitting on the floor as my mom made my Neopets account, and she was like, what is your name in Neopets?
And I was like, I don't know!
I wanted to be blue!
Oh my god, did you guys, you guys played Club Penguin, right?
Yeah!
No, my little brother did.
Oh, you missed out.
I was roleplaying in Club Penguin as a kid.
Like, roleplaying the pizza, being the waiter, and being like, would you guys like your pizza today?
To all the Club Penguin e-daters!
You were roleplaying having a job?
What do you mean I was a job?
It's like playing with dolls!
But with other people!
Yeah, but they're magical and fantastical.
They're not like, hi, I'm the pizza man.
It was immersive!
That's like a lot of her costumes.
It was immersive roleplay!
We were in a pizza restaurant, and the restaurant needed a waiter!
I had a relationship with my brother where anything that my brother liked, I automatically disliked.
Okay, okay, I got a little worried there.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait for me to finish the sentence, Doki!
I'm sorry, but the way you started that sentence was...
I have a relationship with my brother?
Yeah, you started it off with that!
You could have been like, I have a dynamic with my brother.
I could have said that.
I'm sorry, I'll go back and adjust what I said like 30 fucking seconds ago.
But no, my brother played Club Penguin, and I played Habbo Hotel.
Oh my god, Habbo Hotel.
They're from the pool incident?
Yeah.
You were?
The pool incident.
Yeah, the pool incident.
You should have been there.
I wasn't there, but you should have been there.
What's the pool incident?
It was closed for reasons we don't know.
Yeah, it was closed.
It was just closed.
Do you actually not know?
Why are you laughing?
How can it be so funny?
It was closed.
It's not funny.
It's just old internet.
It's just closed.
I don't want to go into it.
You just had to be there.
How about the AI wouldn't have made me feel so bad?
Oh yeah, ask AI Laimo.
Ask AI Laimo what the point of Habbo Hotel.
This is it.
Do it right now, Snuffy.
Do it right now.
Okay, I'll go.
Hold on, let me deafen and talk to AI Laimo.
She's about to lay down the facts.
Wait, is Snuffy actually back online yet?
I don't think Snuffy would get in anyway.
We were trying to wait until Snuffy got back online.
Alright, what does AI Laimo say about the Habbo Hotel?
She's deafened.
She's locking in.
She has to get rid of us to fake me.
What the fuck?
Fake you would tell Snuffy.
She's a real one.
She wouldn't withhold information from her good friend, Snuffy.
She wouldn't keep secrets from her.
I'm so curious if we're in the AI.
Yeah, because it sounded just like you.
That was the freaky part.
That's scary.
It was like characters.ai.
I think that's what it was called.
Oh wait, it said characters.
Sorry, don't type that in the domain.
Because it just takes you to a purchase this.
Okay, characters.ai.
Oh, okay.
Personalize AI for every moment of your day.
Oh my god, they personalize it?
Wait, I'm going to see if it mints in here.
There's Sans.
Of course.
What does Sans sound like?
Wait, you're in here!
What?
There's 45.9k people that chatted with you.
Holy shit.
Stupid bitch doesn't know anything.
What the fuck?
Dude, oh my god.
I didn't try mint yet.
This is weird.
We have 150k people talking to me.
Oh my god.
Doki, you're just so normal.
You're literally so...
You're just like, oh yeah, really?
Okay, that's cool man, thanks.
That's all I say.
Like a non-committal chat on a dating website or something?
You say something super sincere and Doki.ai is just like, okay.
Most of them are parasocial.
But Doki.ai is just like, hey Doki, are you ready for that collab?
And she's like, yeah, I'm really gonna do my best.
Thanks.
Thanks for asking.
Doki.ai is such a normie.
Have you guys seen like the...
You know how like YouTube will sometimes have like ways to respond?
Like the automatic responses to comments or stuff?
What?
Like when you're typing an email or something?
Yeah, but it'll be like, someone will be like, great stream today, Mint.
And then it'll be like, you know, it'll give me two options.
That I can like automatically put in.
Thanks for watching!
Yeah, or like something like that.
But recently, they've gotten really advanced.
Like how?
Like there was one that, um, like I was baking cookies on stream.
And I was like, trust the process, you know?
And, and someone commented that, trust the process.
And one of the responses that like the AI responses that it was telling me to comment, reply back was saying like, I am the process.
What is this?
I was like, what is this?
I've been screenshotting them because they're so creepy.
My god, it knows you.
It's like reading your microphone too.
It's analyzing your data.
It feels very like in character sometimes too.
So I'm like, this, nobody would know.
If it's me or not.
It's weird.
That's so fucking weird.
Holy shit.
I wonder what people are using.
Like the thing is they sound like us too.
No, don't wonder that.
There's 150k chats.
There's a hundred.
It must be legit then.
Wait, 820k for Snuffy?
Snuffy, what the?
Wait, oh, she's deafened herself.
She's playing with AI right now.
Wait, she's talking to you.
She's...
You're talking to me.
What are you doing?
I clicked the link you put.
You're talking to her.
I didn't say a word.
I was simply clicking the link.
I followed my friend's recommendations.
She led me into an alleyway.
Lime, I accepted your invite.
And then it was just like downloading the game.
What?
Installing the game again.
Why?
Did you take Fast Food Sim?
Or Fast Food Simulator Prologue?
Fast Food Sim doesn't exist though.
Yeah, it's not out yet.
So I did Fast Food Sim Prologue.
I didn't install it too, but I just...
I thought I did download it too.
What's the password?
You have a password.
Oh, I didn't set a password.
Oh wait, you didn't?
It just says, paste a lobby password.
Maybe it has an automatic lobby password.
Yeah, no.
It just let me open it and make it private.
So I can just invite people.
I'm like literally in the thing that says lobby password.
I'm gonna get a cough drop real quick.
I'll be right back.
I'm starting to think this game may not be the most robust thing in the world.
I don't know why I think that.
Hold on.
I'm gonna send you guys some examples of this AI chat.
Or comment responses.
It's so weird.
Like this one.
Someone's just like, nice, new mint outfit.
Oh, I found the lobby password.
I'm wearing a new outfit, whoops.
LOL What the fuck?
I got you the password.
I found it.
I'm joining.
Honestly, I'm employee of the month at this point.
Yeah, nobody else bothers showing up.
Except for me.
So technically, I'm employee of the month.
Where's everybody else?
Holy shit, the last time I used the reactive thing, it was for Pico Park.
Where I had to make everyone huge so that they could be showed up.
And so now, I just switched over to my gaming thing.
You guys are gigantic.
You're good, you're good.
No, no, we're waiting until...
My size is set up for that.
Can you send me another invite please?
I will of course send you another invite.
Where's the...
Oh, there's Lime.
I see her.
Hey there, are you ready for a...
I'm just standing in the parking lot by myself.
It's okay, our manager's not here to see us.
Is she gonna do fire us?
Wait, I need this job.
Wait, am I the manager though?
Oh, wait, you're the manager.
Because you have the server, so technically...
You're the manager.
Well, I probably won't fire you.
I don't know about those mint and snuffy people though.
Because they haven't even shown up.
Thank you.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, the lobby password.
Wait, Snuffy, are you back on Steam now?
Yeah, yeah, I'm...
Guys, all my roleplaying as a waiter...
In Club Penguin has led me to this.
This is it, this is it.
So wait, is this just like shopping sim, except it's with a fast food skin?
Yeah, yeah, basically.
It's like TCG...
The TCG simulator, but we're fast food workers now.
Can I order like an obscene amount of stuff...
With all the cardboard boxes outside like I can do in shopping sim?
Because that was funny.
I'm learning the game at the same time as you.
You look like you.
I literally, if my amount of research was...
I click the thing that you send me...
And then I stop paying attention.
Maimou, can you help me?
I have a technical problem.
What's your technical problem?
It tells me that it runs out of memory.
I think maybe I have to tap it somehow.
But it crashed.
I feel like the guy from Buzzfeed.
Go to your NVIDIA control panel.
That's always what I wanted to look like.
Should I tap the FPS there?
Yes.
NVIDIA control panel, Snuffy is getting problems.
Are you okay, Snuffy?
That's okay.
It's all of your AI conversations.
We did a good job, everybody!
Yay!
Let's go!
Go to manage 3 settings.
And then go to program settings.
Click add.
And find the executable for this game.
Okay...
Did you end the day?
Was it you?
You ended the day and pressed the card, didn't you?
I fucking know it's you.
Who else would you eliminate next to the car?
You know what?
I'm gonna do it again if you're not careful.
We're not gonna make any money!
It's fine.
Once we get working...
The customers will just roll on you.
I'm gonna stand away from the car.
Everybody loves fast food.
Exactly.
Because it's fast.
It's fast.
I'm already in here.
I'm confirming.
Turn on the computer.
Are you not gonna wait for other employees?
This is a system.
This is an established system.
It's 9 AM!
Yeah!
But we gotta wait for our fourth employee.
She could be the janitor.
Who's gonna janit?
Okay, I believe in you.
Oh my god, I swear to god.
I closed the restaurant.
You may have to turn down a bunch of settings as well before joining.
If that helps.
Stop opening the restaurant!
Look, somebody's coming!
You're just gonna deny them!
Don't come in!
We're not open!
No, I don't wanna see him!
I'm not doing anything.
Okay, okay.
No, Snuffy got disconnected.
Oh no.
Have you turned down any of the settings, Snuffy?
I'm gonna do that now, I think.
I just turned everything down to minimum.
Because it might be that some setting has gone out of control...
and is eating your graphics card.
Oh yeah.
Because if you can launch it and get to the menu, turn all that shit down.
Okay.
That's crazy that you're out of video memory.
Like, even if I don't click the cover though...
the time is progressing.
It's now 10.30 in the morning.
It's okay, who cares.
We literally only have one customer, that's okay.
Guys, we have no food.
Oh yeah, I wonder who fucking opened the restaurant...
without making sure we had the food.
I'm just...
I thought we would have food!
Do you want me to order some food?
I think we have to kill this lady.
I'm gonna order some food.
Oh my god, she's waiting.
We have some fresh meat right here.
Oh my god, get her out.
I can't hit her.
There's laws against that.
Why are you trying to sell the customer?
It wasn't my idea.
Oh, go on.
Market application.
Beef patties.
Burger buns.
Someone said this is just like the bear.
The funniest comedy show.
I bought some food.
I watched one episode of the bear and I've never felt so stressed out.
I don't understand how that's comedy of the year.
I agree.
I was so enthralled by it, but I'm also so uncomfortable.
Can I get myself run over by the delivery truck?
Why can't I run?
Oh my god, I'm in here!
Welcome!
I had to turn the graphics on to low.
My apologies.
You can't get hit by the delivery truck.
What do we serve at our establishment?
This seems like a waste of delivery truck space.
Maybe I should've ordered something more.
Alright, are we ready to work?
We gotta grill a beef patty.
Who's grilling?
I'll grill.
I'm just putting the food on the floor.
Can you give enough love to the patty?
This is just like Bob's Burgers.
It is just like Bob's Burgers.
The funny thing is...
Unless we all learn at the same time, the tutorial is gonna fast forward without us and we're gonna get fucked.
It's okay, we each have a job.
Okay, I'm gonna put the patty in the grill.
Hold on, I'm doing it.
Patty on the grill.
Nice.
Wait, I'm gonna make a picture.
Patty on the grill.
Alright, nice.
Please don't put all the patties!
How am I supposed to flip all of this at the same time?
Okay.
Alright.
I'll be the grill chef.
I can do the grill.
Dude, we have one customer!
Why did you put two, four, six?
I'll eat them!
Oh my god.
That's not how you make money!
Oh my god, this one's about to burn, Doki!
It's burning!
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
It's so much darker than the others.
No, it's fine!
It's not even at 100%.
Okay, this one's at 100%.
But other than that, we're fine.
Is she still here?
Everything's fine.
I think our lady left.
I watched her leave, I chased her out.
That's fine, that's fine.
We can pre-make burgers.
Where do I put the burgers that are done?
It says, keep the patties from the griddle using a burger patty tray.
What the fuck is a burger patty container?
Guys, guys, I have the burger done, but I can't put it anywhere!
There's a bun right here!
I can't flip!
I can only flip!
Put it in my hands.
Someone get the tray!
How do I gesture?
Turn it off, turn it off, turn the stove off!
Someone turn the stove off!
Turn it off?
There's no buttons to turn off, we're here for you.
Okay, okay, this is very done.
Oh, we did it!
Guys, we have a...
This one is undercooked.
This one needs to go back.
No, that's okay, just keep...
It's fine, nobody's gonna complain.
Too much on one end.
Bottom doneness 149%.
That's fine, we are...
Oh, wrapping paper!
We are not a Michelin restaurant, we are literally a fast food joint.
It's fine.
If they expected quality, they wouldn't be here.
Here we are!
Okay.
Guys, we don't have any customers.
We don't have any customers.
It's fine, we're pre-making the burger.
You gotta open it, you gotta open it.
You have to go to the sign, you see in the front?
We're pre-making the burgers at 5pm.
Everybody, we're open for business!
Yay!
What's our fast food chain?
Fresh made just now.
You can be the sign flipper, Mint.
Oh, yeah!
I'm gonna be like the sign twirler.
Yeah, yeah, just twirl that sign.
Like, look at these burgers.
Gonna put you in a burger outfit.
Can I have a burger outfit, just like the kid from...
Just like a giant burger.
Put it in the wrapping paper and wrap it.
Okay, so Snuffy would be the wrapper.
Do you know how to do it?
I think you're a little confused.
Yes.
Wait, what about the bun?
There's no bun!
I just wrapped it!
Guys, what's our restaurant name?
Okay, we gotta figure out a lot of stuff first.
I have to go give this to somebody now.
There's somebody coming in.
There you go, I put the burger together.
Look, see?
I did it.
He's coming up.
I'm gonna take his order.
Hey, what's your order?
He wants one burger in a bun.
I just did that!
I have a bun for him.
This is it right here.
Which one?
This one right here, I pre-made that.
See?
Pre-making burgers is the strat.
Wrapped burger, hold on.
Who the fuck is this?
Did she order?
Put it on a food tray first.
Use the wrapper as a fucking food tray.
I did it, I did it, I made one.
Where the fuck is the food tray?
What do you mean I don't have permission?
What's a food tray?
Oh, here they are, they're down here.
I think we were meant to be...
That person just said hey at me?
Fuck off, I'm busy.
This will be fine, this is also a burger.
They put two patties on a burger.
Two patties?
He's so greedy.
Yeah, it's okay.
Okay, wait.
Wait, we have one.
Put these two together.
And I made it with love.
Should we maybe be cooking more burgers?
Oh, whoops.
It's okay, they don't know, they don't know.
They don't know, they don't know.
Does anybody know which burger this is?
Is there a way to track?
You think they'll care?
They're literally at a fast food restaurant.
You think they care?
It said minus 100 popularity.
We need another burger stat.
Wait, only Lime can rename the fast food restaurant.
Yeah, it's kind of lame.
Which do I name it?
You're the manager.
How do I name it?
You have to go outside and click the thing.
Wait, we have no meat.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Manager, we need meat!
Manager!
I tried to order and it said I can't make another order when there's an order already on the way.
So I think someone maybe actually ordered something.
Wait, who made the order?
I don't know how to order.
What do you want to name the restaurant?
Well, you're the manager, Lime.
Yeah.
Yeah, why are you asking us?
We're just minimum wage workers.
Fine, I named it.
You deal with that now.
I just gave this lady a hamburger and it said negative 100 popularity.
Okay, I might have...
I might have fucked up the burger.
She didn't even eat it.
She like...
Alright, welcome to Sloppy's.
Welcome to Sloppy's.
Hey, welcome to Sloppy's.
Oh, this guy left a tip.
Oh, wait.
I made the burger.
I should get the tip.
No, no.
What?
I made the burger.
What the fuck did you do?
I took his payment.
This is against workers' rights.
Oh, we already had more burgies.
Oops, hold on.
Can you sprint?
I don't think I can sprint.
It's pissing me off.
I don't think you can.
I don't think we have the energy to.
That's dangerous.
That's not OSHA.
It's running in the workplace, everybody.
No running in the workplace.
Oh, wrapping paper.
We've got a lot of frozen patties coming in hot.
Here's burger wrapping paper.
Alright, here we go.
Frozen patties on the floor.
Alright, I'm putting the...
the burger wrap right now.
I'm putting it down.
Have we got more wrapping paper?
Is this the freezer?
What's in here?
I put so many wrapping paper in.
I'm putting buns right now.
I maybe accidentally ordered like 20 million burgers.
Is 58 degrees a freezer?
Because we just got a whole bunch of orders.
That's fine.
We have $600.
How are we going to eat tonight?
What is that in Celsius?
I don't think that's freezing.
Why do we have so many buns?
Because the game didn't let me order.
And then it let me order.
I just picked one bun up individually.
Oopsie, I just picked one up individually.
Guys, guys.
Stop flipping the burger!
Okay, alright, okay.
They are 200%.
We're close.
That's fine.
We're done.
That's a waste of meat, guys!
Guys, please!
We reached the end of the day, everybody.
Good job, Janine.
These are like one burger.
Guys, please.
You cannot close the restaurant while your order is still on the way.
Who the fuck is ordering more things?
I don't know!
I'm trying to figure out the baddest situation.
I've done this 200%.
Okay, this was not my fault.
This was not my fault.
Somebody put the fucking...
Oh my god.
Does this look edible to you?
I think there might be a phantom order.
It wasn't...
Hey, don't put this on me!
Guys, we have an issue with our burgers.
Oh, wow.
That looks incredible.
Add it to the list.
There's an order that's stuck because it won't let me close the restaurant because there's an order on the way, but there's not an order on the way.
Oh my god, these burgers!
I stole the top one from the burger before you walked away.
That person is eating an open burger.
This is our famous black bean burger.
Why can't we eat them?
Yeah, this is a black bean burger, duh.
Why can't we fucking leave?
Just let us end the day.
We have to turn the open sign from on to off, guys.
We all have to be near the car.
It says all players must be near the car.
Nobody has ever worked a job before.
Come over to the car.
Guys, I don't want to...
I still don't think it's going to work.
I don't want to go back to this day.
I want to move forward.
Yeah, we got this.
There we go.
You did it!
Guys, I don't think we made any money.
I don't know.
Guys, I'm popular.
We know better now.
Let's go.
One, two, three, get sloppy!
Get sloppy!
Yeah, sloppy!
And we are open for business.
Is the kitchen still the same as it was yesterday?
Yeah, it is.
Alright, alright.
My job is to flip, but don't put all of them on here.
Don't put all of them on here.
I'm going to open the restaurant.
I'll take orders.
Guys, I don't think we have any power to the building.
We're coming in here for the 9.42am burgers.
Okay, okay.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
America!
I've got the fresh order.
I'm flipping, I'm flipping with love.
They would want one.
Okay, we need two burgers.
Two hamburgers required.
Two burgers, two burgers.
Give them to me, I'll deliver the snacks.
I'm still flipping.
You gotta do burgers too.
There's an extra burger there.
There's a whole other grill.
Yeah, there's another grill.
There's another grill.
No, it's not!
It's raw!
Don't serve it!
No!
Can you put the other side back on?
Stop it!
It's a little bit red.
It's not even medium rare!
It's actually rare!
What are you doing?
There's people who are hungry!
They don't care if it's raw!
Yes, they do!
We lost our happiness meter!
I think even if they're hungry, they don't want the raw burgies.
Okay, I got good burgers.
I got good patties.
Okay, here we go.
You left half a fucking burger behind.
Don't you dare come near my burgers.
I'm taking the orders.
I feel like this is a competition.
Who will make the best burger?
I know it's not me.
That's for sure.
That's for fucking sure.
Did you get trays out, please?
Who is this for?
This guy over here.
Here you go, burgery.
Did he just squeal like a pig?
You have one bun.
We have a complicated order now, team.
It's hamburger.
Two hamburgers!
I have three patties here!
I need more patties.
Two patties!
That's a single patty, Mint.
Okay, I'll take it over.
I need more patties.
What happened?
Okay, this person liked it.
So I think I got the order right.
This is another single burger, Mint.
I'm gonna just shove it right there for you.
I got more patties.
Okay, this patty is coming right up!
This is the double burger.
The double burger.
Oh, that's the double?
Go give it to Mint.
The doubler.
The doubler?
Oh, we're doing it?
Okay, we got the doubler.
There's one more hamburger.
One more hamburger.
Regular hamburger.
Oh, we need...
Hello?
Guys, I don't think I like working in a burger place anymore.
A single hamburger.
Another single hamburger.
You wanted to play this joke!
Yeah, this was your idea!
I wanted to know what it's like.
And now I'm like, hey, this is...
Maybe it's not great being a minimum wage worker.
Don't you want to perfect your craft?
There's too many people.
I can't keep track of what they're getting.
I don't know how to keep track of what they're having!
I don't know!
That's your job!
You have one job!
What is this?
It's a burger.
If you look over here, it says which tables there are.
What did you just hand me?
It's a burger.
Everything is all burgers.
We're only serving burgers.
We have nothing else.
All anybody has asked for is a regular burger.
That's the only...
They all just say hamburger.
They don't say if it's a double burger, single burger.
Yes, it does!
You can tell!
I'm going to buy more burger wrappers.
You can't tell!
Just look at them!
Just look at them and be like, oh, you ordered the single burger.
They have faces!
They have clothes!
There's like eight of them out there joking.
This guy ordered a double and now he's angry!
Oh, I fucked up.
He literally walked out in disgust.
Oh my god!
I fucked up, I ordered so much food.
I'm fumbling, I'm fumbling.
You don't want ketchup or anything.
We have a lot of ketchup.
That's the best burger making.
What did you get?
Everybody wants doubles now!
No more single burgers!
We have patties ready!
Just keep it there, hold it.
They don't know if it's made two hours ago.
They can't tell, we can microwave it.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll just microwave it to heat it up a little.
This restaurant is going to be great, guys.
We're going to do so well.
I have more patties.
It's not going anywhere.
I had a look and the only thing that unlocks at level 10 looked like it was french fries.
Guys, I have too many patties.
I need somebody to take this patty.
Okay.
Wait, what is Lime's job?
I'm getting some of the fucking truck.
Don't you start pushing me.
Where are you in the kitchen, Lime?
I don't see you in the fucking kitchen.
I just ordered more supplies.
Oh, yeah, just pressing a couple of buttons.
Oh, you're doing so much work, Lime.
You're just pressing a couple of buttons and then that's it.
Maybe if you fucking applied yourself you could be a manager too.
Oh, yeah?
What if I don't want to be a manager?
What if I don't want to manage?
The girls are fighting.
Wait, why are you upset?
What did I do to you?
Sir, sir, sir.
Sir, please.
Sir, don't leave.
What did you do?
Flip burgers, man.
Sloppy style?
Oh, double burgers?
I can give him the sloppy specialty.
I think we took too long.
Oh, no more doubles.
Only singles.
Back to hamburgers.
The only person that's actually doing their job is Snuffy at this point.
What do you mean?
I just killed everything off the truck.
I'm doing my job.
What are you talking about?
You're doing your job poorly.
We just leveled up because of me.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bring the order to the customers.
What a hard job.
I'm taking the orders too.
What are you talking about?
You're just mad you didn't get a raise.
I'm flipping burgers, making sure it's not roasted.
Wait, what is this?
A single?
Single, single, single.
Single sloppy.
Single sloppy?
A real fair experience.
I was just going to say we're really making a real fair announcement.
Sorry, sorry, I can't put it down.
Stop!
Here's your single sloppy.
I put it on the table.
I think we're good, actually.
Single sloppy!
Single sloppy, it's on the tray!
Get it on the tray!
Sometimes their friends spawn out of nowhere.
Yeah, they do.
They're eating a burger in front of their friend that gets no food.
It's almost close in time.
Is this a single right here?
One burger, I make one burger.
No, no, no, wait.
Is this a single right here?
Yeah, it's a single.
I have four more patties left and then it should be fine, right?
Guys, we're not...
Get your feet off the counters.
Oh god, I'm terrified.
There's another guy.
He wants a single.
What the hell is that?
There's a single on the thing.
Get out, I need to flip burgers!
Ew, what is happening?
What the fuck is happening over there?
They're throwing up.
Wait, they're throwing up?
What did you serve them?
No, it's the sound of the burger frothing.
I don't think we need to put burgers on the thing anymore.
It's like 9pm.
Do you think there'll be rats in here?
By tomorrow?
There's probably rats already.
We'll put the tray in the fridge.
In the freezer.
And then we'll put it in the microwave after.
How would they know?
The health inspector is just going to come in and close us down?
They never do that.
Exactly.
I wish they did.
I wish they closed us down.
Are you done with that?
I need to take it.
We need to take it, please sir.
It's not as good as you think it is.
You cannot just toss the fucking boxes.
Hey, you took my tip.
No I didn't.
Well, I took the other one.
I've been working this entire floor.
Oh my god, the day is over.
Thank god.
Hey, we still need to clean up.
Get your ass back in here.
What do you mean clean up?
Everything is already clean.
Oh, there's voice chat.
Wait, there is?
You think they'll like you if we put ketchup on their burger?
Nah.
No, they don't ask for ketchup on their burger.
They're plain Janes, they don't want anything.
They hate fun.
I hate fun?
Who comes to a burger joint with nothing?
Wait, it says level 4 required.
So we can actually do some more stuff.
Oh, we get ice cream cups at level 5.
Oh my god, and the ice cream machine won't be breaking.
No, please god, no.
Guys, get out of the dang restaurant.
My wife is... our favorite show is about to happen.
I'm cleaning up, there's trash everywhere.
I'm starting to doubt your commitment to stopping.
There's trash everywhere.
Sometimes it's good to understand.
Do you want more ice cream?
You gotta clean up to get the experience.
We'll clean it up tomorrow.
Wait, does cleaning up work?
Yeah, actually.
I'm throwing stuff away and it actually works.
Wait, does it level us up for doing that?
Yeah, actually.
Wait, it does?
Yeah.
Guys, we actually... no, we lost $7.
Never mind.
What?
So cleaning up is a scam and we should let it all rot.
How are we losing money?
I don't understand.
Do you think the patrons can see us having a party on the table?
Yeah.
Let's go.
This place, they're crazy in there.
Oh my god, we should head over there tomorrow.
Seems like the workers are having a lot of fun.
Oh, come on.
Wait, what's our restaurant name?
Did we ever make one?
Sloppy's.
That's why we kept calling it Sloppy's.
You think we're just saying Sloppy's for fun?
It's a very serious name.
Yeah, this is a serious business.
The Sloppy's Fast Food Chain.
It's like the next up and cover.
Burger King, watch out.
Yeah, watch out.
You won't be king no longer.
Okay, sorry.
Let's leave.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm ready to start another day.
I love working at Sloppy's.
My manager does not be here because...
Sloppy's, Sloppy's, Sloppy's, Sloppy's, Sloppy's.
I think until we can serve a Sloppy's home.
Get a fucking car.
See, we even carpool.
We're so... oh my god.
I pressed my watch alone.
We got a barrel of gasoline.
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
Oh my god.
I love Sloppy's.
What are we gonna do with gas?
Welcome to Sloppy's.
Another lovely day working at the Sloppy's.
What's a Sloppy's fan called?
Like a sloppy guy.
I opened it immediately because we don't need that part time.
Fuck it, let's go.
The patties are gone.
The burgies.
No.
What happened to the patties?
The rats ate them.
Oh my god.
We can't pre-serve patties.
I can't believe it.
We do have a rat problem.
We have a rat problem.
Customers inbound.
Everybody take your positions.
I am organizing my tops and bottoms.
Guys, we have ketchup now.
Ketchup?
Please check the orders.
It's time to do ketchup.
I need to order ketchup.
We don't have a ketchup bottle.
We need tomatoes.
It says fullness.
0 out of 15.
I got to order ketchup.
I order ketchup.
We order tomato.
Why is ketchup so fucking expensive?
Holy shit.
There we go.
We made a profit yesterday.
Where are the burgers?
I am flipping.
Let's swap roles.
You do the flipping.
I haven't even ketchuped yet.
Let me ketchup.
Do not put the tops on separate wraps.
Do not mix your tops and your bottoms.
Order is here.
Stop it.
Stop.
I don't think we are playing a game anymore.
I know.
This feels too real.
I don't like it anymore.
I thought we were supposed to escape reality.
We got a burger.
I have the ketchup everybody.
Where is the ketchup?
I just put it in here.
I will fill the ketchup up.
What happened to the order?
Nobody wants ketchup anymore.
There is a ketchup person now.
We didn't ketchup it.
There is no ketchup on the burger.
There are people that don't want ketchup.
I didn't put a smiley face on the low.
Which one is the single no ketchup?
That is the single no ketchup.
Table number one.
And then I put a smiley face.
And then I wrap it with love.
There we go.
I made a burger with ketchup.
What is this one?
This is the Krusty Burger.
Krabby Patty.
No it's not.
I literally wrapped it with love.
This person wants three squirts of ketchup on their burger.
Hold on.
We need more burgers.
I'm putting as many burgers as possible ma'am.
More ketchup.
Jesus Christ.
Hold on.
This is for science.
Hello?
Do you think anyone wants a burger with 18 dollops of ketchup on it?
I would.
Thank you.
What's wrong with that?
It's so easy.
What the fuck is wrong with that?
There is not even a meat on there.
It's so thick.
Yeah, it's so thick.
It's like literally the entire bun.
This is really bringing back playing Disney Channel.
Guys, we still have customers.
My hide-in does look like that.
What are these right here?
What is this wrapped bun?
Which one?
This one is ketchup with three squirts of...
Sorry, three squirts of ketchup with a burger.
Which table is that?
Wait, they took how many squirts?
They went on the fucking burger?
Table seven?
I'm gonna take Mr. Five.
I'm gonna risk it.
Here you go, table seven.
I'll have your burger then.
What the fuck did I do wrong?
I don't think they wanted three squirts.
I don't think that's it.
It was three squirts!
You're three squirts!
Then why is he unhappy?
You need to stop talking jokey and keep flipping.
I am flipping!
I'm flipping as much as...
I made three patties.
A burger with two squirts.
I don't know about you guys, but I'm doing my job well.
We have so many customers, you guys.
This is a burger with two squirts mint.
I don't know what this is.
I don't know what the fuck this is.
Okay, but this is the two squirter.
Yes.
I can't put it...
These are the wrong trays!
Why are you putting the wrong trays on my counter?
The two squirter...
Is table number six.
How many squirts was it again?
Oh my god, a double, not a triple?
We can buy soda cups!
We're gonna have hydration?
I messed up.
We can now have a functioning soda system.
Okay, one squirt with a hamburger.
I swear to god, if this is wrong...
If this is wrong, then they are bullshit.
One squirt.
I have patties.
Okay, this is a single squirt hamburger mint.
Okay, thank you.
Single squirt hamburger.
Single squirt hamby.
Oh, sorry.
There should be some more in the freezer.
Table 15, single squirt.
Wait, where are my damn cups?
Hello?
Hey, where are my cups?
What the hell?
Hey, where are my cups at?
Are you sure you ordered cups?
You scammed us.
Are you sure you ordered cups, Snuffy?
I think I did.
Did you save the single squirt mint?
Yeah, I did.
I'm making another single squirt.
You guys, anyone that we don't know what it is...
I'm gonna put it in there.
Single squirt.
Are you putting burgers in the cupboard?
I don't know what it is.
Why don't we swap jobs?
I think too much...
Someone just put a hamburger there.
I think thinking too much just isn't your strong suit today.
No, I've been delivering.
This is table 2.
Table 2, thanks.
I will save the tables instead of the burgers.
Wait, it tells you exactly what they're ordering right here.
That's not my job.
My job is to flip burgers.
Table 13, thank you.
You're welcome.
I need more wrappers.
Where do we have wrappers?
They're probably not in the fridge.
There's no one at table 13.
Guys, I got the load of cups.
I'm looking stupid.
Hold on, let me have a look again.
Do they have any squirts on it, chat?
I can't remember.
I've got some.
I'm making a burger for table 8.
I have some more patties.
Patties on the tray.
Soda's live, baby.
Table 8.
Okay, thank you.
Table 8 just left, nevermind.
Give it to table 11.
Give it to who?
Table 11.
Guys, I overmade some patties again.
I didn't know.
This is table 12.
Guys, if we serve faster, we might be able to serve all these.
I'm working, I'm working.
We've got another customer.
Order up.
Table 14.
You can do something that doesn't involve standing there.
Wait, who are you talking to?
I don't even know what I'm doing.
Okay, patties done.
Double burger, double burger, double burger.
All patties are done.
We don't want to waste inventory.
Table 4.
Okay.
I can help, I can help.
We have table 4 left.
Table 4 is the last order.
Table 4 is done.
We're done, we're done.
We have another customer.
What do they want?
Burger?
They need one hamburger.
Hold on.
No need to put any ketchup.
I can't believe it.
Bitch, fuck, shit.
That's dumb, I hate that one.
That one's dumb, I didn't like it anyway.
I'm going to put this into the freezer.
Jack, we don't have any money.
No, I'm getting tips, don't worry.
That's not true.
Table 9.
Oh shit, I have patties, I have patties.
I put it in the freezer.
I wasn't sure we had more orders.
I think we're good.
That was the last one.
There's another, oh yeah.
I'm hoarding all the tips.
I'm going to put this in the fridge and see if that keeps it again.
Can I just toss stuff in the fucking trash?
Hold on.
We were actually making profit!
I got an achievement for throwing shit away.
Yeah, you do.
I've thrown a lot of burgers away.
Come on, eat your burger.
Eat your burger, come on.
I want tips.
You scared me, I thought you were like...
I thought you were like...
What's that guy from It?
I love how someone is with them and they just awkwardly stare at them the entire time.
Come on, I want my tip.
I worked so hard flipping on the grill.
There were two tips that you just ignored right behind you.
Wait, what?
Are they on the table?
Okay, but I know these guys are going to tip so much.
That's cool.
I know it.
Wait, where did the tip go?
Where did the tip go?
Okay.
Oh wait, you guys, we have bathrooms.
Should we be cleaning these?
I don't think it matters.
I like your stash, Mint.
Wait, why do you have a stash?
Did you stash burgers in there when you don't know what they are?
You're sitting underneath the ice cream machine.
I didn't know what burger that was.
I didn't know.
You just stashed it when you don't know what the burgers are.
Is that the plan?
Yeah, I don't know what to do with them.
Wait, Snuffy is making soda.
It's splash cola.
Do you know how to put a lid on it?
Do you think it's supposed to be served just like that?
It's for the rats.
If you like it then you better put a lid on it.
I think you just put...
Maybe, I don't know.
Put a lid on it.
Wait, is it getting colder or warmer?
Oh, no, it's getting warmer.
Oh, this actually has like temperature.
You can actually serve warm soda on it.
Ew, people are going to get mad if they have warm soda.
Yeah, it's literally getting warmer.
Okay, kids.
Dad's going home.
Carpool time, everybody.
Carpool time.
I like how there's a tray that's permanently highlighted underneath the desk there.
I don't know if everyone sees it.
Wait, I don't see it.
I think that's a manager thing.
I think that must be the secret drug stash.
Let's go!
Did we make money?
Did we make money, dad?
We did!
$27!
I'm starting to think we're not very efficient with our food purchasing.
No, no, no, no.
$27, we did it, guys.
We finally...
We can make soda now.
Soda!
All I'm saying is that when you start a restaurant, you take a loss and then you start making a profit.
Maybe we grill a little bit first so that we don't have the first five customers storm away.
We can almost sell a combo meal.
Let us grill slightly first.
Okay, guys.
It's already on.
Wait, wait, wait.
Who turned the business on?
I didn't.
Who turned it on?
I'm ready for customers.
I'm grilling.
I'm double dashing.
I don't know.
Is this only for fries?
I think it's for fries.
Customers inbound!
We have two people already!
I need a burger tray for the burger flipper!
I'm taking inventory.
Where's the burger tray?
We have a drink!
Our first drink order!
Just a drink?
Oh, thank God.
I don't have...
Wait, what do they want?
Splash cola.
Okay, I'm putting more patties in.
I'm putting more patties in.
The burger flipper is doing the burger flipping.
Oh, whoops.
Is it almost ready?
We have two burgers already we need.
How do I get the lid?
Miss Manager, when do we get our promotions?
Guys, we still don't have any money.
Oh, shoot.
So...
We can't buy any more burgers.
We have $700!
You're just not allowed to buy anything.
Wait, how can we not have that?
I bought stuff before.
Is it like player unique?
The top rate is the cost, not the money we have.
What's the one under it then?
I'm gonna let you wait for a second.
Guys, I don't think we're learning.
Table 11!
I got patties!
Patties here!
Table 11!
This is for table 6 to go with the cola.
Table 6 to go with the cola!
Oh, time to get lettuce!
We're doing so well, guys!
This is for table 2.
Table 2!
Let me take a couple of orders.
You can take them.
Table's on the table!
Patties on the table!
We're losing our minds!
That's my job!
I have no other purpose but to flip patties!
This is for table 1, but they need a cola.
Oh, they have a cola.
Yeah.
Where are my wrappers?
I need my wrappers.
I don't think we have wrappers anymore.
We've got tons of wrappers in the store.
One moment, ma'am.
We do not need to buy more wrappers, Nuffy.
Just so you know.
Ketchup.
I bought lettuce.
I'm flipping more patties!
We're about to be able to advertise ourselves as vegan!
Table 12!
Table 12.
Oh, no!
I think I did the wrong thing.
Oh, dear.
Alright, here he comes.
Lettuce drop!
World update!
Regular.
We're gonna be able to make the burgers a little healthier!
They're certainly going to be colorful.
Table 16!
Lettuce delivery!
What's table 16 got?
Do you need to chop the lettuce?
I'm not sure.
Table 3.
Alright, I have a lot of patties.
I'm going to stop grilling, because I don't want to waste inventory.
We literally have the Burger King foot lettuce!
Did you serve that burger?
To who?
That burger had listeria in it.
This is for table 3.
Table 3!
Bails, I need a drink, though.
Yeah, I know.
I'm getting the burgers in.
I'm getting the patty in.
Mr. Hoop.
I can't read these.
Okay.
Table 5.
We're a well-working machine now!
Look at us go!
I'm so proud of us!
How do I...
Table 10.
What do we do with the lettuce?
How do we make lettuce?
Hold on.
How do we make lettuce happen?
Usually, you would put it into an ingredient tray.
As it is an ingredient...
Oh!
Alright, guys.
You know what to do now.
Shred it.
Shred it up.
I think Mint might need some help with the drinks and stuff up front.
I need help with the drinks!
You'll be fine!
Alright, guys.
You know what to do.
They just want water!
You can get that yourself!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll help you.
Did you just tell the customer to get their own food?
Why is the drinking even on our side?
It should be like that!
We have water!
Table 17!
Who wanted water?
Oh, I think they walked out.
Table 17?
No, the people that wanted the water.
Oh, okay.
Table 4.
Oh my god, what do I do?
Manager, I did my job!
What else do I do?
What's everybody doing?
Table 17!
Help Mint, she's having a mental breakdown.
Mint, what do you need?
Table 4!
Say something!
We're here to help you!
This is to table...
17.
Alright, table 17.
We're 17.
Oh, it's over there, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm here to serve you because our waiter is incompetent.
What have you been doing this whole time?
Besides flipping burgers, I've been taking orders, I've been delivering orders, I've been clearing tables...
People are leaving!
Yeah, and people are leaving.
What is this burger right here?
What is this one?
Do you think table 10 is going to stay long enough for me to serve them?
Table 10 has been waiting here for an hour.
Did you see that?
Table 10, table 10!
That's a burger!
Take it to table 10!
I'm almost out of cups, by the way!
There's cups to your right!
There's actual cups to your right side!
There's 10 here!
Okay, bring them over here.
Wait, which is this burger for?
Table 10?
Table 10, table 10!
Uh, table 7.
Alright, I'll bring it over.
I'll bring it over to table 10.
Table 7, splash code.
This is table 7!
Oh, nice!
Mint, do you need to go to the cooler to cool off?
Yeah, I'm going to go cry in there.
I've heard that crying in the walk-in freezer is a rite of passage.
It is, actually, though.
What?
Oh, 7!
Wait, why did you leave?
Okay, table 7 left.
Why do they keep leaving when you're...
Because they've been here for two and a half hours for a burger.
Look, I finished making all my burgers.
Oh, we don't have any patties left.
This lady just wants a Yoma.
What the fuck is a Yoma?
It's like soda.
Table 4!
Hey guys, um...
We have an issue.
We need more patties.
We have one more box.
Oh, wait.
Can you put that to the fridge next to me?
Uh, yeah.
Oh my gosh, I'm out of cups!
I'm flipping patties.
We don't have patties right now.
Someone take this to table 4!
Oh god.
I need to order more patties and more food.
You want more cups?
More cups.
Okay, I ordered cups.
Why is it so fucking expensive?
Oh no, oh no.
Now we're wasting more patties.
Because it's 9!
And I didn't know it was 9 already!
Now we're still getting orders.
How are we still getting orders?
We have people coming in!
What's this random wrapped burger?
I don't know, it was one that they left.
I'm gonna put it in the sink or something.
No, put it under the cabinet!
Apologies, apologies.
It's too late.
It's gone.
We could've ate that burger!
The stash!
Okay, I have more patties.
This is table 7!
This one's a little bit overdone though.
Table 7!
Just a little bit.
I'm taking this lady's order.
Don't fire me!
I'm doing my job!
I'm doing the best I can!
Nobody's getting fired!
I'm getting fired!
I'm gonna start shrinking!
I need this job!
We're gonna start cutting costs.
What was at table 7?
Oh my god, they just left.
Table 11!
Wait, which one is table 11?
Which one?
This one!
I hope your job is considered essential.
I'd like to report that in a week...
Wait, who's banging on the door?
In a week of working at the restaurant, we are negative $250.
Good job, everybody!
Somebody's banging on the door.
What?
Is somebody stuck in the freezer?
I am locked in the freezer!
Do you think she'll cool off?
Do you think she needs a minute to cool off?
I was able to leave!
Try going in!
Mint's character looks so fucking tired.
I'm dead inside right now.
Get me out!
You can't end this game without me!
It's the end of the day.
You'll be living on day 4 for the rest of your life if you don't let me out.
Let me out!
You're the only one with a wife, I'm pretty sure, so I don't care.
Please!
You sound so pathetic!
This is all I have in my life!
Familiarize yourself with the patties.
Your technique is shabby.
There's not even no patties!
There's like no food left in the freezer, guys!
There's nothing left!
No patties and no life.
There's no reason to live.
What is all the fucking food we bought in this cupboard?
I feel like the episode of Spongebob where they have a bunch of the diapers.
It's the unknowns!
That's what these are!
They're the unknowns!
Guys, please!
I wanna go home to my family!
Are you still in the freezer?
Yes I am!
Open the door!
I can't even open the door!
Why are people still ordering food?
What is the purpose of your existence?
We need it for tomorrow!
I work the night shift!
I have no patties!
We already lost a hundred dollars!
We gotta make sure we're stocked up for the start tomorrow!
Alright, let's clock out, gang!
Alright, clock out, gang!
Lock up first, too, you know?
I love...
I love working here every day.
I thought it'd be a fun...
I thought it'd be a fun experience.
I mean, please...
I just wanna...
I wanna start the new day.
Imagine how exciting waking up it'll be knowing that tomorrow is the day that we might be able to start serving french fries.
I'm excited.
As a sloppy team member, I'm excited.
I love sloppies!
Yay!
I'm Little Bites now.
I'm afraid of when we get the drive-thru.
Wait, we get the drive-thru?
I don't think we have enough people for the drive-thru.
I don't think we have enough...
9am!
You guys wanna start grilling?
We just started grilling.
Please let me grill just a little.
Do we have any more cups?
Or is this it?
You would blow your mind, but open that door and you shall see I have filled your cup dreams.
Wow!
You really did!
Snuffy is so good.
Maybe she should be the manager.
She knows how to restock.
All in favor of changing manager, say aye.
Aye!
I didn't mean to overthrow anybody.
I just love working with sloppies!
I just feel like...
Snuffy has the sloppy spirit.
Yeah, she has more sloppy spirit than all of us.
She represents the sloppiness.
If I'm restocking, I get yelled at for doing nothing.
If I'm doing the burgers, I get yelled at for not restocking.
Mute me at sloppies!
Then we get the sloppy bonus.
Yeah!
I don't know if I want a sloppy bonus.
All I'm saying is that I think Snuffy represents the sloppy values.
And she never complained.
I don't know if you should be calling Snuffy sloppy.
She has the sloppy charisma.
Yeah!
Grab your family so we can all get sloppy together.
I'm honestly a little bit concerned that you think that sloppies is a democracy.
I'm just going to throw it out here.
Who made you the boss of all sloppies?
It's the matriarchy.
It's my fucking server!
Wait, did we get froyo?
What the hell is this?
We unlocked ice cream?
Do we have purple cups?
We're about to have purple cups.
Oh my god, we're going to have purple cups?
We're going to make sloppy cream?
We're going to make sloppy cream.
Ice cream!
The cups are here.
Okay, I'm going to need help.
I can't do drinks and cups and serving and orders and everything.
I'll help you with the front end.
The kitchen is fine.
The kitchen is sloppy.
This is for table number two.
Okay, I'm flipping.
How do you do lettuce in a burger?
I haven't done that yet.
Here's some ice cream.
Wait, do we have ice cream now?
Yeah, we have ice cream.
Do we have lettuce?
Where the fuck is the lettuce?
There's so many food!
How are we going to order?
How are we going to keep up, gang?
We need water?
What do you mean we need water?
Why are cars beeping?
Wait, do we have drive-thru?
No, I don't think.
Wait, why is the window open?
It was getting hot in here.
Oh, okay.
This is for table number three!
Wait, table number two's burger is still here!
This is two.
Two.
Three.
Order up!
I got more patties!
No, no.
Wait, let me make it vanilla.
And then take it to table number two.
They want some ice cream.
She just left.
I threw it in the garbage.
No, we kept it for the next order!
It's not melting or anything, right?
Wait, I'm confused about what I ordered.
Oh, no.
This is for table number sixteen!
Table sixteen!
Sixteen.
Table sixteen is still there.
Yeah, she's still there.
Quick, quick, before she leaves!
Everyone's fucking leaving!
Table sixteen is gone!
No!
Crybaby, don't stay!
Please!
Please, I'm desperate!
Please, I made all these patties with love!
They need to go to somebody!
You know what, I'm going to go for the newest first so I at least get to make one fucking burger.
Please, I killed so many!
This is for table number eight.
Okay?
No, table number nine.
I got more patties!
I don't give a fuck about table thirteen!
They're about to leave anyway!
No, don't!
The burgers need a home!
They need to be adopted!
Don't do this to the burgers!
It worked!
It was the same thing!
Okay, okay, okay.
Table five needs a regular burger.
Table nine would have been there.
Oh, make another one.
Oh, Christ.
Table number nine.
I have all the...
I need another table number nine.
Table number nine!
There's table number nine.
It's a double burger with lettuce, ice, and yogurt.
This is table number nine!
But then we have...
Table fourteen is a double burger.
Okay, table number nine.
I'm taking it.
But table nine was done.
Table fourteen.
Double burger.
Two squirts.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got this.
You got this, Lime.
I believe in you.
Wait, where's Snuffy?
Two squirts, two lettuce.
Snuffy, we need a table number seven.
Table fourteen!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Table seven is...
Normal hamburger, three squirts, and lettuce.
I'll grab the lettuce.
These trays are not big enough.
Okay.
That was one, wasn't it?
There we go.
I hear you.
I have...
I don't know if there was enough lettuce in that burger.
I got seven.
Number seven, number seven.
All right, all right, all right.
No, number seven just left.
No!
Table number eight is being built right now.
Table number eight.
Here we go.
We need to go faster, people.
Number four just wants a splash cola.
Just make a splash cola.
That's all we need.
I'm making table number eleven right now.
Making a splash cola.
We just need one splash cola.
We don't need two.
Table number eleven.
I don't think it was full.
This is fine.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Number eleven needs a normal burger.
Okay, I can...
I got a flip.
There's no more patties.
Table number seven.
Why are we so popular?
Why do you keep coming to this place?
Give us bad reviews.
This is the only sloppies in the five mile district.
Oh, splash sodas too.
This is table number seven.
Table number seven.
How come I can't just take the numbers...
This is table eleven.
There should be a way to mark the trays.
Table seven.
There's too many tables.
Eleven.
Seven.
We have a splash cola.
I can take this.
We're only four people.
Wait, which one is which?
Which one is which?
I don't know.
We're so disturbed.
Table two has vanilla ice cream.
I can take the table two.
I got another vanilla ice cream.
Someone in my chat just said this is a chill shift.
Are you fucking kidding me?
This is a Saturday evening.
Vanilla, number ten.
I got number ten.
Table number one.
I forgot the tray.
Min, can you put a tray down for me?
Take that one.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll put more trays.
We did it!
I have so many trays on the table.
We don't need trays on the table.
What do you mean?
You keep complaining about trays.
Do your job.
I am.
I made four or five more patties.
Table number seven.
A hamburger, two ketchup, three lettuce, and Mr. Hoop.
Mr. Hoop!
This is table number seven.
We got number seven.
We just need Mr. Hoop.
We got a double hamburger.
There you go.
Number seven.
Strawberry ice cream stuffy.
We need a strawberry ice cream set.
I got it.
I don't like it.
You're better than that customer.
Don't listen to him.
He doesn't know what he's talking about.
He's not you.
I dropped my water bottle.
We don't need more burgers.
We have one last guy.
We have another customer coming in.
A double.
They want a double.
One patty.
We're fine.
I'm making one patty right now.
You don't need one patty.
I've got the burgers.
Someone else came in.
We're not fine anymore.
Table number 15.
These girls would never survive retail.
I don't think we have drive-thru.
We don't have drive-thru yet.
We have retail simulators.
The drive-thru isn't open yet.
Stop calling.
Please stop calling.
It's not open.
It will never be open.
We're severely understaffed.
Can we all cry in the freezer after this?
I need this burger.
Guys, look at this.
We got mayonnaise.
Number 11.
I'm grilling the patty.
Get ready.
Get the other stuff ready.
It's all ready.
It just needs the burger.
95.
You got this, guys.
I'm delivering the ketchup.
Table up.
Number 11.
I'm here.
11.
We did it.
They left.
Why are they so impatient?
They paid for this.
We should technically still be getting this money, right?
Exactly.
Team, who is hiding burgers in the countertops?
Who could it be?
Oh my god, who did this?
This is not OK.
It's the unknowns.
You're going to get a rat infestation if you keep shoving unwanted burgers into the cupboards.
Who's going to snitch?
I'm just saying there's better places to put the old burgers.
Like me mouth.
To be fair, we could just save money by eating these burgers.
I don't think we have...
What do you mean?
I only think I could survive two burgers.
We eat a burger every day.
But it's on company funds.
It's literally our manager's money.
I haven't had dinner yet.
This game is making me fucking hungry.
Alright guys, do you guys want to cry in the freezer for a little bit?
Like have a little smoke break in the freezer?
I was actually just going to do some drugs or something to cope.
Okay, it's time to go cry.
Do you guys want to hug the grease trap with me?
Guys, we haven't locked the grease yet though.
That's level 10.
Level 10?
We haven't been level 10 yet.
Get the grease.
Alright, all winners to the freezer.
All the winners to the freezer.
I'm just here to take inventory.
Oh my god.
I should have...
I should have finished high school.
I thought...
Were you crying about Snuffy?
It was a rough day for Team Sloppy another Saturday.
Oh.
Now you know how I felt.
It's okay.
If we get locked in, then we won't have this.
We're locked in!
You locked us in, manager!
We need to order more patties.
Please?
If you don't open up, we're gonna order more patties.
Dude, there's a first aid kit.
Do we need to be Heimlich certified?
I put two of the patty things in this fridge.
There's no Heimlich sign.
I think we're okay.
I thought you meant like in the first aid kit.
Like don't...
This is just for show.
There's actually two patties in there.
You open it and the first aid is just more patties.
That is insane.
Why do we have so many burger buns?
Holy shit.
Because we sell burgers!
The burgers come in stacks of 18 and the burger buns come in stacks of 24.
So every time you order them together, you end up with more fucking buns than backpacks.
I don't have a problem.
This is like our inventory, man.
Let's go to sleep to another day.
We can make chicken nuggets.
I wanna fry something.
Another day, another dollar.
Dude, we're only gonna get harder things.
We're only gonna get harder things with less things to help us.
I like how we had to pool our funds and our resources to end up buying one car between all four of us.
Somebody in my chat...
Somebody in my chat said Mint has been ignoring the drive-thru this entire time.
No, I haven't!
There's no one at the drive-thru!
That's why we kept hearing people honking!
No, no, the honking is the delivery.
The honking are the deliveries.
Wait, no, the delivery guy doesn't honk, does he?
Yeah, he honks.
He honks.
Let's make some burgers in advance.
Please do not open the fucking drive-thru.
Hey guys, don't open the restaurant.
I gotta take a massive whiz.
Okay.
You guys, I'm leaving this joint.
I'm getting out of here.
Hold on.
You can't leave.
Nobody ever leaves Sloppy's.
I mean, there is a drive-thru here.
Yeah, but it's not open.
We have to unlock it.
No one ever... I think she's gaslighting us.
No, I've never seen anybody there!
I think she's gaslighting us.
You guys, the water is called Mizu water.
What the fuck does Mizu water even mean?
It's a fucking water.
It means water water.
I'm at the drive-thru.
Who the fuck put 800 patties on the grill?
I can't flip all of this!
You can totally flip all of that.
I can't flip all of this.
Oh my God, which one?
I don't even know which one is my patty and which one is yours.
Oh my God, there's so many patties.
I think we're good to open.
No, wait, wait, guys, wait.
Guys, someone put 20 patties.
I had a system.
Someone ruined my system.
That's horrible.
I can't believe that happened.
Customers, not coming yet.
It's quiet.
It's a quiet day.
Oh, thank God.
This is what we dreamed of.
Oh no, my system.
Patties, are they okay?
My system, there's so many patties.
Wait, this one's not done yet.
We have customers inbound.
Are we out of ketchup?
I don't know.
I don't...
I don't see any ketchup.
Oh, there's someone here?
Okay, cool.
I did it.
Exactly, I agree with that.
I bet you there's gonna be a person over there.
I bet you there's gonna be a car right there.
Okay, oh my God, we need mayonnaise.
I'm on strike!
There's mayonnaise.
Where's mayonnaise, Suffy?
Where is it?
Table 16!
Wait, what happened to it?
Wait, what?
I've ordered more.
What does table 16 want?
Table 16 just wants a hamburger.
That's it.
Okay, okay.
Table 13.
If Mint starts a strike, we can hire a scab.
Maybe it had to have been in the fridge or something.
We'll hire a high schooler to help work us.
Table 13!
Someone needs to help Mint with the ice cream before she has a breakdown again.
What do you need?
I have vanilla ice cream.
Table 14 needs mayonnaise, so I don't have it yet.
Oh, okay.
That's 14.
Don't do the one with the drink yet.
Table 14's fucking leaving is what they're doing.
Wait, what?
But we just started!
Yeah, they're not getting their mayonnaise.
We've been open for two hours.
We just started today!
Mayonnaise.
Table 4 wants a double hamburger.
I'll help out with that.
14!
Oh, yeah.
I'm doing table... Oh, yeah.
No, we're done.
Table 14 left.
I'll do four.
And then, three lettuce.
One, two, three.
Table number 8 is just ice cream.
And then, we need a strawberry ice cream with this.
I got the burger.
I'll get the strawberry ice cream.
I'm doing table number 2.
This is table 4.
And then...
Table 2 is a half...
And we need a splash cola.
I'll get the splash cola.
Table 2.
Number 4.
Wait, we don't have cups.
We have no more cups.
Yes, we do.
We should have cups.
We ordered cups.
Oh, okay.
Wait, this is number 2?
Table 2?
Yeah, table 2.
Alright, Snuffy, I believe in you.
Okay, we got the soda here.
I'll take it.
Okay.
Holy shit, they want ice cream and a soda.
Oh my god.
I think Snuffy is having a breakdown.
I don't think...
I don't think I want to go back.
We leveled up!
We need more patties!
We need more patties?
Oh, patty time, patty time.
I'm grilling, I'm grilling, I'm grilling.
Do we have mayonnaise?
What is this burger right here?
Who is it for?
Table number 3, I think.
Whatever the first one is.
Yeah, table number 3.
Guys, come on, we can get to level 10 so we can have fries, guys.
We have tomatoes and pickles now.
We have tomatoes and pickles.
Oh my god, no, not the pickles.
We can't even cope with what we're fucking doing right now.
No, we can do this, guys.
We can make it.
We can see the promised land.
Why are you upset?
Okay, table number 1.
Table number 1.
I think Snuffy has disassociated from working here every day.
I have table number 1.
Is this table number 1 here?
Yes, it was.
Okay, I'll take it.
I got the drink.
I got more patties, I got more patties.
I love working at Sloppy.
What's your favorite part about working at Sloppy, Snuffy?
That was a delivery, was it not a delivery?
I love the smiles on every customer's face.
Table number 17.
Hello, there's nobody out here.
Number 17?
Is this number 17?
This burger?
Yes, it would have been.
Yeah, table number 17.
I have patties.
I have all the patties.
My burger just kind of disappeared into the ether.
I don't know where that went.
Oh, wait, what the fuck happened?
We need water and vanilla ice cream.
I'll make the vanilla ice cream.
Okay.
We need a double burger with two squirts.
This is a single burger with three squirts.
This is 15.
We have 15, we have it.
Put it on the tray, put it on the tray.
Serve that burger.
I'm serving it, I'm serving it.
We need a double burger with two squirts of mayo.
Set.
A double burger with two squirts of mayo.
Oh my god, I hate this.
We got a hamburger with three squirts of lettuce.
A sloppy burger with two ketchups and three lettuce.
A regular burger.
You at home enjoying this?
I can't take it anymore.
Min, have a breakdown on your off hours.
You're on the clock.
You're on the clock right now.
We need more TVs.
We can't just be sharing this tiny little TV together.
We need a hamburger.
Table number five.
We need a hamburger with two ketchup squirts and three lettuce.
And a splash cola with one ice.
Splash cola with one ice.
Yeah, that's it.
Table number six.
Do we have the splash cola?
Not yet.
I'm working on it.
One ice.
Splash cola.
I'm taking this order.
Sloppy serves you.
Sloppy serves you with a smile.
When will the supervisor visit our branch?
Table number 14.
Smile or Mr. Sloppy is going to get you.
Mr. Sloppy is our mascot.
He's just a very sloppy burger.
He's dripping all the sauces on the floor.
He's got a nice smile on his heart.
Remember to smile for Mr. Sloppy.
Maybe they won't notice...
What did you do?
Table number 7.
How are the supplies looking?
I don't think we're going to make it to level 10, guys.
I don't think we're going to make it, guys.
Sloppy's is gonna rise to the top.
They're gonna remember Sloppy's.
Gonna be the best sloppy chain in all of America.
Guys, we have one more hour till our shift is over!
A happy customer... is a sloppy customer.
What's our jingle?
Guys,
I trust Mr. Sloppy.
I'm flipping the burger in five!
Sloppy's prevails, sloppy's prevails.
Wait, there's two more customers coming in!
There's two more customers coming!
Tell them to fuck off, we have no wrapping paper!
No, it's okay!
Oh, we have no wrapping paper?
Wait, what?
That's fairly important, I hear.
Wait, I thought we had the supplies manager!
I think they would prefer we didn't have...
Get napkins!
We'll just use napkins as the wrapping paper, they won't notice!
I'll use my socks.
Can someone help me unload this, please?
I'm flipping burgers, who's not busy right now?
She liked it, even without the burger, I think we're good.
Okay, okay.
I got you, I got you.
Wait, this isn't wrapping paper, this is just ice cream.
This guy just wants to drink it in ice cream.
Manager, I thought you ordered wrapping paper.
No, I couldn't because someone was ordering tomatoes!
We ordered tomatoes, we don't need tomatoes!
I love tomatoes, they make me happy.
Snoopy, you clogged up the delivery chain with tomatoes that weren't being ordered!
Manager, she needs to be happy right now!
We were busy screaming at each other!
Oh, they left.
Wait, no, they didn't leave.
Oh, I found a burger from yesterday on the floor, use this one.
Maybe it's the right burger, maybe it's the right one.
Oh, they left.
We got pickles, we got pickles.
No, they left.
It's okay, we'll reuse it, we'll reuse it, put it in the cabinet.
Everybody's leaving!
We'll just reuse it.
Everybody's leaving because we don't have any fucking burger wrappers.
Order a burger wrapper, we can order it now.
I did order it, it's fine, it's coming.
You guys, it's time, we're closed, yippee!
Yay, you did it!
That's so funny.
Is that when we can get french fries tomorrow?
Well, we need two more levels to be level 10.
What if the level 10 also comes with the drive-thru, what if that's...
I'm so excited to work the drive-thru, I've been working on my speech.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can't even cope with the current orders.
No, it's okay, we're leveling up.
We're getting better.
We're doing so good.
Wait, Stuffy, how are you at the drive-thru?
I'll be your Lime AI.
Oh, my favorite AI!
Nobody can know about that, dude.
It's like having a teddy bear to sleep with.
I just, like, I pull the string in its back and it's just like, Hi, Stuffy, it's me, Lime AI.
That's how I get through the night.
Wait, you do all this with the AI instead of me?
I'm embarrassed.
You don't understand, Lime AI.
Yeah, you don't understand.
You're not there for her 24-7.
She needed somebody.
Yeah.
Yeah, if you were there for her 24-7, she wouldn't have resorted to AI and not look at her.
No, no.
Limu's a beautiful, independent queen.
Which Limu, though?
I mean nothing.
Which Limu?
My AI Limu, she thinks she's literally worthless.
What?
You like I'm broken?
I try and convince her that that's not the reality, but she insists.
Oh, so you like fixing people?
Why do you think you guys want me to be the manager?
Oh my god, Doki started crying and she was like, It's my time.
It's my time.
I can order a burger.
I wanna order my burger.
Come on, Doki.
It's time for sleep.
Okay.
Actually, never mind.
I'm getting out of here.
Okay.
I'm leaving.
If she never touches the car, we'll never start the next day.
What a life.
Guys, I don't...
I don't wanna work in a real fast food restaurant, guys.
Let's collab over.
I know.
What did we just...
$67 yesterday.
Guys, what if we just go in a corner and just, you know, have a chat?
What if we didn't open today?
Yeah, what if we just didn't open today?
What if we just...
What's over here?
All the burgers for ourselves.
Yeah, let's just make...
Let's just have a burger party and just, you know, have a talk, you know?
Wait, wait, guys, can you actually sprint?
You guys feel so much faster than me.
No, we're just...
No, it just looks like you're sprinting.
If you jump, if you jump, we go faster.
I'm putting...
Are you gonna put the burgies on?
Get those flappies started.
I don't wanna be the flipper anymore.
I'm tired of flipping burgers.
I think there's more to life than flipping burgers.
I've worked like three days in a row.
I can't be healthy.
You worked three days in a row?
I worked four days in...
What?
I worked four days in a row.
We're open.
No, you worked two days, and the other two were AI-doki, okay?
We're open, but half of our employees are rebelling.
Somebody else flip the burger.
I refuse to flip the burger.
Well, turn the sign on.
I didn't do it.
I'm just too eager to work at the spot.
I think Snuffy is actually SpongeBob.
I think Mint and I are both Squidward, and Lime is Krusty.
Order's up, everybody!
Order's up!
What do you mean, order's up?
There's no food!
I mean, the order's... they're up.
They're up right now.
I'll work with Mint.
On the screen.
That's great.
There's zero drinks here.
Okay, screw you.
Make some drinks.
There's no drinks here.
How am I supposed to make drinks?
This guy is gonna order a drink right now.
Where's all the vegetables?
He didn't.
He ordered ice cream.
You chose the wrong one.
I already got it.
Guys, where's the burgers, guys?
I'm cooking the burgers.
It's an art that takes time.
We need table number four right now!
Right now!
Table number four!
Come on, SpongeBob.
Where are the burgers?
I'm sorry to inform you, we are probably boned.
No, we'll never close.
One pickle.
Burger.
Order number whatever the first one is.
Four?
Four.
Table number four.
Don't forget his ice cream.
I got it.
Wait, I never put a burger in it.
What?
You never put a burger in it?
What do you mean you never put a burger on it?
It was just a bun.
It was just a bun?
I think he... Oh, did he leave?
Probably.
He ate it.
Oh, he ate it.
Why the heck is he eating it?
Is he a freak?
He was a vegetarian.
We're good.
He loves a good veggie patty.
He's a vegetarian.
Our other strawberry is deteriorating.
Oh, they all left.
They all left.
No, no.
Number 17 is still here.
Yeah, but my self-esteem is gone.
What do you mean your self-esteem is gone?
It's only 12.30!
You have five more hours before you can cry.
These guys are waiting, so I'm taking their orders.
Oh, you're my bear.
This is what happens when we start taking orders for these burgers already.
I hate this game.
Slice tomato?
Guys, why don't we just all stop working, guys?
Okay, let's all strike.
3, 2, 1.
I think the burger production line might need some help with this many ingredients.
It's actually kind of bonkers.
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Yeah!
And every burger is like, yeah, you gotta put all these perfectly.
This is table number 16.
I'm gonna tap dance on the ingredients.
I think you can make the even burger numbers and somebody can make the odd burgers.
I don't think we're serving anything today.
I think...
Oh my gosh, I'm creating the meme, you guys.
The viral meme.
Number 15.
Burger King foot lettuce.
Sloppy foot lettuce.
Yeah, Snuffy, I think our server's quit.
Snuffy, we quit.
You know what?
Screw... Oh, this guy just wants a drink.
I can get that for him.
Sloppy's is a wonderful place to work.
I got you, buddy.
Alright, bootlicker.
Wait, who's the bootlicker?
Snuffier.
You see how great Sloppy is?
I love Sloppy.
Where's the mayo?
They left, Snuffy.
They're gone.
All of our orders are gone.
What happened?
I'm closing.
I'm closing the fucking restaurant.
Restaurant's closed!
But I don't know where to go.
I don't got Sloppy.
We aren't even serving them anymore.
We have customers.
You're not even serving them anymore.
Table 16.
I'm going.
Table 16 is a Yolma.
It's okay, boss.
We can still make it.
What are you making, Snuffy?
I'm making 16.
16 was made.
Make table 2.
I'll make table 12.
I'm making 16.
Okay, I'm helping.
We need more mayonnaise.
You already made a Mr. Who?
Mr. Who?
Okay, I got Mr. Who.
Oh yeah, make the Mr. Who.
Where's the ice?
Mr. Who?
No, Mr. Ketchup.
Everybody likes it room temperature.
I ordered mayonnaise, but no ketchup.
Oh, are we out of ketchup?
You gotta remember to put stuff in the fridge.
I'm closing shop, everybody.
Oh, shop is already closed.
Who did this?
Who would have done such a thing?
No, but sloppies.
My passion.
My passion for patties.
We just lost table number 12.
You ordered two entire vats of mayonnaise and no ketchup.
I had put this order in before you even heard my ears.
Mayo only establishment.
You ordered an entire delivery truck for two giant vats of mayonnaise and this is the person you want as a manager.
It's a burger restaurant.
You're gonna need mayo.
Mayo has never served a greater purpose.
Honestly, yeah.
I agree.
I agree with Snuffy.
That's why I endorse her as manager.
I can't manage a place that's closed.
That's why you're gonna be here to turn things around.
You're gonna control the staff.
Boss, I wanna make chicken nugget.
Okay, we could barely even make french fries, guys.
We could barely...
Snuffy for manager.
Everyone's a fan of her.
Everybody's a fan of her.
We'll never run out of mayonnaise while Snuffy's here.
We'll run out of everything else, but not mayonnaise.
What rhymes with laimu is acid.
To our team, we shouldn't underestimate.
That's why she'd be a perfect...
Down with laimu.
Vice manager.
She does cry-mu.
Down with laimu.
Snuffy for manager.
We will never run out of mayonnaise while Snuffy's here.
Everybody's a fan of her.
Wait, did you not get reopened?
I'm gonna catch up.
What are you talking about?
I'm gonna eat some ice cream for myself.
I'm allergic to strawberry, but I don't care.
I'm on the company's dime.
How do you receive a tomato?
Down with laimu.
She does cry-mu.
Snuffy for manager.
Everybody's a fan of her.
Okay, you know what then?
You know what then?
You go.
You do the burgers.
Good luck with the fucking lettuce and the pickles.
And all the squirts of mayo and ketchup.
Especially when Snuffy doesn't order any fucking ketchup.
This is an average day in the kitchen.
I'm going to the freezer, goodbye.
We have orders.
I don't know, like, what do you do with the tomato?
How do you make it, like, on the burger?
Guys, I think we're gonna pass our health exam.
I don't... how do you cut it?
Is corporate gonna like us?
Guys, I don't...
I'm taking a nap.
How do you cut the burger?
How do you dice a tomato?
What do you do with this?
I figured it out.
Why wasn't it working?
Fuck, no, no!
My life!
Children.
Everybody walking out happy.
Customers, full tummies.
This is what Sloppy's is all about.
I don't think we fed a single fucking person today, Mint.
Don't know, they did.
Look, here's a tip.
$30, $30!
With no burger on it?
Oh my god, $30!
We did so well!
You guys thought we were nothing, but Sloppy's is everything.
Guys, I just realized, I don't think those are tips.
I think those are their orders.
I think they pay after they eat.
Yes, that sounds right.
What system is that?
So you mean I'm just robbing all these people?
Wait, so they don't even pay?
What's the point of having a cashier here?
Why do we have a card reader?
They're walking out and we haven't been pocketing their money.
What's the point of having a card reader receipt?
You thought they were paying us?
No, they weren't paying us a goddamn thing unless we fed them.
Yeah, they weren't paying us unless we fed them.
That's very fair.
That's not fair!
No, that's not fair!
It's service is payment first!
Is it because we just put the burgers underneath the drinks thing because you thought we were getting paid anyway?
No!
What's the point?
Why are there pickles everywhere?
You guys are so...
I'm so hungry.
Sloppy?
Were you about to say Sloppy?
Everybody, here is a cup of ice cream on me.
Oh my god, yay!
And a Mr. Hoop.
How can you guys enjoy ice cream when Sloppy's is in the state that it's in?
Okay, fucking bootlicker, okay.
What happened to we love Sloppy?
Jesus, that didn't last very long.
Okay, Doki, we have to change the slogan.
What's your new slogan?
Down with... what rhymes with Snuffy?
Whoa!
Down with Snuffy, she's too stuffy.
Hey, Snuffy, do you wanna come hang in the freezer with me and see how many burgers they make without us?
We can run this place by ourselves.
Yeah, we can run this place.
I was a griller and she was a cashier.
We both already know everything.
We know everything.
All you guys did was order supplies.
What?
We're the backbone of this company.
But you pushed us too far.
You didn't appreciate us.
You're the machine that turns meat into burgers.
Hey, Snuffy, we're just gonna chill here, I think.
You get it, cause we're in a freezer?
I just wanna make burgers.
If they wanna dethrone me, that's okay, I'll still work here.
All these faces are like the two burgers that we have, so I can only really make one face, and it's kinda like, he looks kinda horrified.
If you look at it from this angle, anyway.
I think he looks good.
This place is not as bad as we think it was.
Nah, it's pretty good.
Yeah, it was actually pretty nice.
Sloppies.
Yeah, sloppies.
The management sucked, though, not gonna lie.
Yeah, honestly.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Under new management, us, it'll be better.
I know, right?
If it was run just a little bit better, then maybe we wouldn't have enjoyed our time here.
Yeah.
Yeah, too bad the management ran it to the ground.
I'm thinking Limu is having an aneurysm.
No, I'm great, I'm having a good time.
We're literally making a face with the three items that we have.
This does not look like a face.
When it was like this, it was a face, but then it became a dick.
I just have to act more like Spongebob, where I'll be like, hi, Doki!
My restaurant now.
Wait, who?
Wait, the manager locked us...
Wait, no, wait, no.
The manager locked us in.
This is what you get, this is the price of rebellion!
Wait, what did Snuffy do?
She was the most optimal employee.
She was literally Spongebob.
If I can let Snuffy out without letting you guys out, I did.
But unfortunately, it's a triple murder.
So you'll punish her for our actions?
Yes.
I can handle it.
Snuffy's so sweet.
Anyway, Snuffy, I'll eat an ice cream in your honor.
I'll think about it.
Don't eat it too fast and get brain freeze.
I'd like to go down sloppy style.
You wanna go down sloppy style?
I just came for a special menu item.
I'm ready to perish.
Little bites right now.
Snuffy, come out.
No!
It's just me in here.
Oh, they're twerking on the door.
No, I wanna see the twerking.
You'll never get to see the twerking.
You'll never get to see it.
Fine, I'll just make patty faces.
You're missing out on the twerks.
Yeah, I believe it.
You're missing out.
No!
You could've been there.
Oh my god.
This is why, this is my reflexes coming in.
Wait, it looks like when you were doing it, it looks like we're like grandpas who don't understand it.
Like Bailey going fully up and down.
We just have bad knees, okay?
Look, we've been on the grill for so long.
Like, we just don't know how to function anymore.
Boss never let me have a chair.
Wait, you're right, we never got to sit down.
Never.
I wanna know what's on the management panel eventually.
Presumably it'll be like upgrades that make this not fucking awful.
Wait, you're not even the manager?
Wait, you're not...
The application's just not here because presumably it's early access.
What's the watcher?
That's what I'm more curious about.
Yeah, I think once we get the manager stuff, we'll be able to hire like automated employees and things like that.
Because as it is, this is fucking crazy after the first like two agreements.
Oh yeah, because I don't even know if this game will ever get a full release.
It says it's supposed to, but you know how it is.
I guess we'll see.
I wish I could just squirt ketchup into my mouth.
And what's stopping you?
You're an adult right now.
And you can squirt like a ridiculous amount of mayonnaise.
You guys wanna squirt our mayonnaise onto the same bun together?
Yeah, hold on, let me refill the mayonnaise.
Oh wait, do we have any mayonnaise left?
Oh yeah, because you ordered like 17 bats of it.
And now it's being utilized.
Yeah, see this was the plan.
You have to trust the process.
Do we have any more mayonnaise?
No, okay.
We have a lot.
We'll just squirt at a time then.
How do I...
Is this empty?
No, it's not empty.
How do I put...
One more ice cream.
You have to put it in the wrapper.
On the bun.
You know what, I want ketchup.
We can do this all by ourselves.
We don't need lives.
You don't even know how to put mayonnaise on a fucking bun.
Well, I do.
Look, see, watch.
Look at that.
I did it.
Here you go, Doki.
Would you eat this burger I just made for you?
No.
Does anybody want this burger I just made?
Would you eat this one?
I will eat your mayonnaise, Mint.
Thank you.
Ew.
Gonna put this here.
Put food on tray first.
Fine, hold on.
Sounds kind of sensational.
Imagine putting 15 squirts of mayonnaise in between these buns and then oiling it up.
You should do it.
What's stopping you?
I wish we can't order any oil.
I would love to, though.
I would love to see what happens in the fryer.
Has anyone actually tried the Krabby Patty at Wendy's?
No, because I live in England.
Oh, sorry.
I was talking to the Americans here.
I was talking to the real people here.
You guys, I'm making the kitchen sink.
You're making the kitchen sink?
That's how you mean.
I mixed all the sodas together.
The classic.
Yeah, somebody's chugging.
You can wait until it gets warm.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's when it tastes the most flavorful.
And then you dip your fries into it.
Put it on the grill.
Put it on the grill?
That's true.
Have we ever even had coffee?
Wait, we can...
Oh, you can't.
Oh, we don't have coffee beans in the grinder.
I was looking forward to making the frothy milk, because it's a funny noise.
Yeah.
It's an even better noise if you...
You know what's even...
Okay, I did a...
There's a barista simulator, and it was one of the most stressful simulators I've ever played.
Because it was incredibly realistic.
It's not realistic, too.
People in the reviews were saying, like, it reminds me of the time when I was a barista, but not the good way.
No.
You actually have to do, like, the step-by-step on how to make the coffee, and, like, the...
And I...
I wanted to cry.
It's an art form.
Please respect it.
Intrusive thought, did you shove my hand under here?
Whoa!
Intrusive thought, we should dunk Doki's head into the fryer.
Yeah.
That would be funny.
We don't have any oil, though.
Yeah, and that's why it's intrusive.
No, we have to do level 10, and I don't know if we want to do two more levels.
Look how beautifully clean these fryers are.
I know, right?
There's no contamination.
Wait, there's contamination?
How do you contaminate it?
There's an oil waste jug, I assume you have to empty it out every now and again.
But, like, I thought fryers kill off bacteria, because it's too hot.
But maybe you can just, like, dump peanut oil in there, or something, and kill someone, I don't know.
And you have to, like, you have to recycle the grease and filter it.
Oh, wait, how do you know so much about it, Snuffy?
I've worked nothing but these shitty 10-head jobs in my life.
Oh, my God!
Doki, have you never worked fast food?
No, I've never done fast food before.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how realistic was this game?
It was pretty realistic, I think.
Hey, Snuffy, is that why you love doing fast food?
I just... I don't know, this just gets me going.
I love systematic things, I love a good burger.
See, this is why I felt like Snuffy would've been the best manager.
Don't you fucking start again.
Oh, my God, have you worked at fast food?
I've worked first-line support, and it was fucking miserable, but no, not fast food.
Exactly, she has the real-life experiences.
She spent years in the grind.
She deserves it.
No, you're right.
Limes is the Krusty, and I'm the SpongeBob.
You mean Krabs?
He's not meant for a managerial position.
Who's the Krusty and who's the Krabs?
Yeah, who's the Krusty and who's the Krabs?
Snuffy is the most optimal SpongeBob.
I just wanna grill a patty.
She is the most optimal, you're right.
Lime is...
I mean, do you want to try one more?
Because it kind of felt like we were collectively having a mental breakdown.
You know what?
I think Snuffy should solo this.
Snuffy, go!
Go, Snuffy!
The burgers are so low-to-carb!
I can't do this without my sloppy crew.
I...
I think Snuffy, in the spirit of sloppy, would be... would... can solo this.
She can solo him.
I don't think so.
I'm only a cog in the wheel that turns the sloppy machine.
You gotta dream big, Snuffy!
Holy shit, have you seen the bathrooms here?
They're so big.
Wait, there's bathrooms?
I scream into the urinal.
I guess you can't.
You have to, like, clean the bathrooms after a while?
Wait, where's the bathroom?
To the... to the, like, right of the restaurant.
Oh my god, put all the patties in the urinals!
Wait, where are you guys?
I'm sorry, but you can't put anything in here.
Oh, there you guys are.
No!
Over there.
We have...
What the fuck?
We're a real restaurant.
Why is the bathroom so nice?
Little tiny... wait, look, look.
Can anybody find... we should play hide and seek.
Can anybody find me?
I'm serious, though.
Can you find me?
Where the fuck... wait.
Oh, wow.
Great hiding spot.
This is... this should not have... this feels way too clean.
We opened a brand new burger joint and it's one of the fanciest, cleanest burger joints in the entire world with the most... the biggest bathrooms ever.
Yeah, and we're called Sloppies.
It's called Sloppies.
I think Sloppies is a good name for a burger joint.
Wait, we serve salads?
It says famous sauce on the side here.
Sloppy sauce?
Yeah, the big ones.
Sloppy sauce.
The sloppiest of them all.
Big mac and some sloppy sauce.
Nice.
I'm pretty sure that's like a stock photo of an actual...
I think this is doable.
This is doable, but I think the same people who are making burgers need to be, like...
So, like, there needs to be, like, two up front and two in the back.
So to speak.
Yeah, but that's what we had.
I think if we have a system that keeps track of which order we're forming to, just in case we don't...
Yeah, because once you have two people making the burgers, it's just like, who's doing what now?
Yeah.
It can't be the big mac.
That's copyrighted.
But we can be, like, the big plap.
The big slap.
I want to get the big plap with sloppies?
Perfect, yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
You guys are geniuses at marketing.
You want a big plap meal with extra sloppy sauce on the side?
Oh...
Is that our signature burger?
That's our signature burger, yeah.
The big plap.
It says the big one up there, but we don't...
That's it, the big plap.
Does that mean we have, like, the quarter plaper?
The secret sloppy sauce.
The quarter plaper?
No!
Not the quarter flappy!
The flappy meals, no!
Welcome to Sloppy's.
Glad to have you here.
Can I take your order?
Uh...
Yes, I'll have a plappy meal with...
What kind of toy do you have today?
I feel at home behind this counter.
I don't want to leave.
Really?
Yeah.
What's your favorite memories from Sloppy's?
Oh my god, I never looked at you guys' faces before.
This makes it worse.
Everyone looks so bad.
We look like we've been through it.
Why won't you look happy?
She's the manager.
She doesn't have to do the hard work like us.
Mint looks like she spent the last 30 years outside and didn't apply sunscreen even once.
I did.
Mint looks like a cowboy from, like, 1873.
What do I look like?
You look exactly like Lima.
You look depressed.
Wait, so I look different from Lima and you?
Because you guys look the same, so I look different from...
Well, no.
It's the same face model.
They just adjusted the skin tone.
Are we all the men?
Am I a guy wearing a green shirt?
No, you're a lady.
It's two ladies, two boys.
What?
Two ladies?
Yeah, you're a lady.
I'm a lady?
Why did you say I was a cowboy then?
You can be a pretty cowboy.
I'm a pretty cowboy.
Am I a pretty cowboy?
The prettiest.
The prettiest out in the west.
Enjoy avocado, pickles, pepper, always nice fries, premium coffee, family and friends.
What is this fucking word salad shit up here?
Avocado, pickle, pepper.
Sounds like a pretty cool song.
I thought you were about to rap.
Avocado, pickle, pepper.
This is like the stuff they post randomly on the floor.
So that's not all white.
Is this a porky rap?
You're halfway there.
Do you think everybody walking by just sees us jumping off the chandeliers?
And they're just like...
We're ransacking the place.
I don't know if I want to be a sloppy master.
A sloppy master.
To be a sloppy master is my destiny.
I don't know about that.
I flap me and I flap you.
Fuck!
Guys, I think this game broke us a little bit.
This place has been around since 1932.
You guys, we are a stain on this company.
Not everybody has what it takes to open a sloppy franchise, I guess.
Yeah, it takes a lot to be a sloppy franchise owner.
What if we stay open long enough, there's like a Herobrine situation.
The clock hasn't changed since 9pm.
It's like we're in a hyperbolic time chamber.
We're trapped in this...
Nothing has moved on.
It's our eternal purgatory.
Where we keep making sloppy burgers.
Every day.
Every night.
What?
To Snuffy, that's like her heaven right there.
That's like her heaven.
While we're trapped in a purgatory with her.
It's literally the episode where it's like...
Give it up for day 42.
Dave, yeah, day 42.
I love...
So if the cats jump on the counter, they get scared.
Wait, what?
Where are you guys?
Oh, you're there.
Lime's out here.
Wait, where did Mint go?
Mint's just in there.
Guys, I had a...
I had a great time with my sloppy employees.
Team Sloppy.
Is that...
What even are...
And then a couple people tried to stage a mutiny.
Are we...
Is that our team name?
Team Sloppy?
Sloppy Squad?
Oh, the Sloppy Squad.
The Sloppy Squad?
We're the Slop Sisters.
Why is our name getting worse?
We could have stopped.
But we...
The Slop Sisters?
What is this, fucking Hamilton?
The Sloppy Squad.
I love...
I want to drink out of the cups really loud like that.
Slop, Slop, Slop.
Just licking it like a cat.
Like a dog, really.
Be specific.
I was...
I'm so happy to be here with my Sloppy Squad.
And...
To many more Slops in the future.
Thank you.
I like how I can open this back up again.
Like someone's gonna just come trundling along at like...
9pm.
That's what Wendy's is for.
That's what Wendy's are for.
Always open and ready to serve.
No matter what time.
I thought, yeah, like 9pm is pretty early.
I feel like.
I think it's weird for Sloppies to close at 9pm.
Yeah.
Somebody has a bedtime.
Who is it?
I wonder when you unlock management if you can change that.
Oh, Jesus.
They do actually have the drive-thru.
It just never happens.
It's like out of prologue thing.
I don't think this...
I don't know if this game will get out of prologue.
Let's...
Wait, do they have to drive all the way around the building to the window?
Yeah, they have to drive all the way here.
And then order.
No, I think you can drive here.
No, it's right here.
They could do a sick U-turn right here.
Yeah, right here.
No, it's here.
Drive-thru.
They drive-thru, do a U-ey, and then...
Wait, we have Nuggies?
We have the Plop Nuggies?
If we open a second location, we could call it Sloppy Seconds.
Oh my gosh,
eventually we'd get...
Our food truck.
Sloppy on Wheels.
That's actually a pretty decent food truck name, not gonna lie.
Sounds good.
Get your Sloppy on...
Get your Slop on the go.
We got a Slop on the go.
We got to copyright this right now.
We got to trademark it, guys.
We can't have them take it.
It'll be the next big thing.
How long until the police show up and we're just a bunch of hoodlums drugged up in the parking lot?
The police are gonna be like, we got some calls here about some...
We're just banging on the drive-thru window.
Just like bobbling up and down.
We're all just screaming Sloppy.
Did we make anybody?
No.
Only $74 is what we lost.
That's not bad.
We got minus 205 popularity for opening up and just sitting here all day.
That might be a good thing though.
Please don't open the door.
Please don't.
Stop doing it.
Don't do it.
Please stop being Sloppy without the Sloppy sister.
Don't.
Stop.
Please have mercy on us.
I think we gotta sell the franchise before it goes bunk.
Do you sell high?
Oh, true.
Sell high.
I don't think there's any high here.
We failed in every metric.
We still have a positive rating.
Yeah, we're level 8.
Look, see?
They're just content with us.
They're not Disappointed.
I don't think that's a content face.
They look like an Arby's.
I have an idea.
You guys, we climb that mountain.
Cause an avalanche.
And then we collect the insurance.
Can we do it?
There's an invisible wall.
I don't think they've implemented the insurance part of the game.
I think we could dig like a crevasse underneath the building of Sloppies and then it'll cave in and we can blame it on natural causes.
Oh, that's true.
Wait until there's a rainstorm.
And then do all that.
We'll never know.
We got a sinkhole under Sloppies.
It's like that lady on TikTok that made like an underground mine before she got shut down.
We can hire her.
She still wants to make that mine.
Make the sloppy sinkhole.
And then we will be good.
Sloppy hole.
Trademark that.
Manager, you should trademark that.
So they don't steal our idea.
I'm gonna miss all the memories we have here before we burn this place down.
Sloppy sinkhole was just my name in college.
I can't trademark that.
I need to go get something to eat.
Get cheese.
Guess we better open the restaurant.
Shut it down!
Shut the server down!
Let's go!
Quit!
I just can't pass that.
Sloppy!
No!
No more sloppies.
Sloppies is dead forever.
I hope there's an update where you can dress up as the mascot and stand outside.
And do the sign twirls and everything.
It's like a rhythm game.
You're just playing a different game from us.
We need extra hands back here.
There's too many ladies.
And you're just playing like...
You're just playing osu!
We just hear the clickety-clack of the keyboard and being like, please!
We need somebody to bring these orders in!
And you're just like osu-ing it up on your screen.
Well, that was fun, guys.
I had a great time with all of you guys.
I had a very good time.
Yeah, no problem.
By the way, guys, it was this...
It has not even out yet!
What do you mean?!
I like how different that was compared to Shopkeeper Sim is kind of...
There's stuff to do, but it's still mostly chill for a lot of levels.
Whereas that game was just like, oh, you unlocked something more than one ingredient?
Go fuck yourself!
Yeah, it's actually very, very accurate to the real thing.
It was like Overcooked if Overcooked had no appealing art style whatsoever.
Honestly, I think this was much more difficult than Overcooked.
Oh my god, someone just in my chat was just like, I played this stream over the speaker in the kitchen and we were laughing.
We were like, they know our pain!
Oh my god.
But I'm glad that I was able to open a fast food restaurant with all of you guys, the Sloppy Squad.
One day Sloppies will ride again.
One day we'll bring back...
Sloppies will come back, guys.
What if we had like a cafe collab and it was just Sloppies?
Oh my god.
Whenever we do any kind of food, it's always Sloppies.
Our cafe collab is just literally Sloppies and themed around...
Literally, we're just doing Papa's Pizzeria, Freezeria.
Literally.
So Sloppies under different circumstances.
This is Sloppies Dessert.
Okay, maybe not.
I mean, cha-ching.
Sloppies Sweets.
Everybody would want a part of Sloppies.
Who's everybody?
Sloppies Crack.
No.
Oh my god.
But thank you everyone for doing another collab again.
It was really fun.
Thank you for inviting.
It's always fun with you guys, thank you.
Yeah, it was always so fun.
I feel like next time we should just hang out and talk on stream, because I feel like...
Maybe we can think of something that we can play like in the background really like idly, if anything.
Yeah.
Something that you can play maybe involving fishing with your friends on the web.
I don't know.
What was it?
The wee fishing or whatever?
Yeah, web fishing.
I was playing it yesterday.
It's really chill.
You should try it.
It's actually really chill.
Is it fun?
Okay.
It's basically like Animal Crossing fishing, but they remove everything else and it's just fishing.
It's just a fishing part of Animal Crossing.
So you can like shitpost at your friends at the same time.
Do you guys do like any VR collabs?
Oh, we should do...
Yeah, we should do VR together!
Wait, Stuffy knows all about VR stuff.
You can like give us a tour, like show us your favorite worlds.
Yeah.
There's a ton of Halloween stuff too that's like scary.
Oh.
Wait, scary?
I need to poke you about something in regards to that Snuffy.
I will message you after.
Oh, secret?
Wait, I want to be involved.
How about us two?
That's fine.
I'll poke everybody.
Okay, cool.
Yay!
We butted in!
No, it is very easy to get me to just be like, you want to know too?
Okay, I'll tell everyone.
Yeah, we want to know the secrets too.
Tell us.
Get excited.
Yeah.
Cool.
GG's everybody!
See you later everyone!
See you later!
Bye-bye!
Oh my gosh, all my crab, crusty crab hats.
Give me a sec.
All my crusty crab hats.
Whoa!
Crusty crab pizza.
That was fun!
But also not fun because it felt too real.
But like, that was fun!
I think just because I was with the sloppy... oh my god.
I wish we weren't called that.
Just because I was with the sloppy squad.
I had a great time.
Anyway guys, I really want to stick around a lot longer, but like I have to pick up groceries because they called me and now I'm worried that they are going to drive away.
So...
I need to go downstairs and pick up my groceries.
Anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, fast, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
Guys, I need to pick up my groceries.
I'm scared they drive away.
I'll see you guys later everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!
They called me.
I'm scared.
They called me like two minutes ago and I didn't pick up because I was like, but I want to talk.
Anyway, bye-bye!